would you rather be on a desert island
with me with pasta are you asking me if
I would rather eat pasta or eat you it
would be pasta
[Music]
welcome to night-in night-out
the show will reek impair a home-cooked
tasty recipe to a night out at a fancy
restaurant today we're going on not one
but two dates and then at the end we're
each going to pick which one was the
better date this race episode it's my
favorite what my favorite pasta is our
go to today we're going to be making our
own baby alright I'm so drawn to the
idea of a kitchen has flour all over it
and like so romantic
the dough together let's just circle
back to who cleans up the kitchen well
we're gonna make the pasta dough yes 3
eggs eggs you verse the guys who told
you not to worry about
give me your nuts did you know that it's
not like this yeah have you read you I
guess not that's a good man butter good
yo Jimmy beat sir Johnny pasta gnocchi
gnocchi see you in the kitchen this is a
tasty recipe that allows you to make
your own ravioli using an ice cube tray
we got a choppa butternut squash you
know you're doing great accion strong
girl love it onions the garlic
we olive-oil it yeah some pepper yeah I
gotta get that salt and pepper don't
even try it
hey leave it into the oven
can you use a food processor we almost
forgot the oil
all right that was so much what have I
been doing all my life so now put it in
the refrigerator for half now this is
where we always get too drunk drop it
how about this guy this looks like some
sort of a ninja blade swinging us across
the room I love getting things social
how are you you know I do like cooking
with you despite how much I make fun of
you for it like making a mess
you're pretty fun cooking with me yeah
very nice no I got a a handprint on your
butt now I think we're ready to put the
filling in our raviolis you know what I
just need to use my hands you're right
what's a little more of a mess yes let's
make our raviolis ready foot okay cute
little ravioli nuggets oh we have a
little hole here no crap and now we got
our pasta cutter here you want ridgey
pasta or smooth okay I want Richie to
probably how my ancestors made ravioli
so they're gonna be done when they move
and finish it off we're going to make a
brown butter sauce with sage and now
let's add in some hazelnuts oh oh it's
starting to get brown cool down the
butter add in another path and then a
little bit of lemon juice I think I'm
ready for these rafts okay those in
there I split open smoosh it back
together
I just stirred a little too vigorously I
got very excited I love this too like
just a ritual cleansing that is so
dangerous
well we gotta cleanse our space if that
lights on fire this date is over that's
not gonna be good that's a good idea
let's crack one of these open yeah
look at that's delicious okay me too
Oh mom I love how the butter sauce is
mixing with the butternut and there's
something acidic in there
it's the lemon hmm that was clutch oh I
love how you put it in your mouth and
then you just saw it go spike wait like
a little savory gusher what every damn
day if I could only eat one meal it
would be pasta do you think the
restaurants gonna be better than our
pasta oh no this is pretty good yeah
let's go get changed and find out
[Music]
so we are going out to a very fancy
Italian restaurant it's called the Ponte
Ristorante what I'm looking for in a
pasta on fancy night out
definitely candles definitely tablecloth
I want to be treated like I hear you you
want the princess treatment it's all
about when you bite into it what is it
like good shouting I got sheriff at
they've got you my name is Freddy Vargas
Executive Chef here at the Ponte I went
to culinary school two years after
college when they understood of New York
been out here about six years I really
fell in love with Los Angeles so today
we're gonna feature I Clint Mezzaluna so
Mezzaluna being F moon behind this was
actually trying to make it taste like
eggplant parm we actually take eggplant
we score them we stuffed them with
garlic rub them with a good amount of
extra virgin olive oil some rosemary we
use and we'll roast the spider that
puree it a little bit in the mobile
coupe or a food processor if you use at
home we'll mix that with some ricotta
and then we actually take eggplant dice
it up and we'll salt it and press it
overnight and then we'll deep-fry that
just a Philly okay so I haven't will
shape the pasta I make the Mezzaluna
what are some tips for making pasta at
home and shaping it nicely
definitely ring molds pasta molds and a
pasta cutter yeah we used ice cube tray
I've never used an ice cream truck you
let the Mezzaluna cook just until they
float you wait about a minute a little
bit of that pasta water I'm gonna finish
this a little bit of parsley
Ruggiano and we have here tomato sauce
that we made with cherry tomatoes of the
garlic some oregano and here we have
some ricotta salata just dried we pulled
up we just toasted in the oven so it
gets nice and caramelized on the outside
a little bit of micro basil extra virgin
olive oil then you got it Eclair
Mezzaluna oh my god I like it it's so
colourful this is very this is very
decadent oh I can't wait oh that's nice
I'm ready Cheers
[Music]
Walmart garage that literally bouncing
your mouth and the inside it's just so
flavorful but it's got like a little bit
of texture there's like a little bit of
crunch you still get that kind of like
eggplant parmesan oh my god this might
be my favorite meal of that there is a
perfect size to Arab yoli and I feel
like it is about this yeah it's like if
I am really ambitious as you put it all
in my mouth at once but otherwise it
cuts perfectly into two little pieces
absolutely and it just makes the perfect
bite that this wine also is such a
lovely pairing oh yeah hey an ugly
antique oh this is like taking a bow bow
a bow yeah it's like this is your day
it's like I'm laying
hammock is surrounded by puppies it's
like a string quartet that could a
Titanic just sinking down a flavor hole
are you like gonna keep doing that how
we've had two dates mm-hmm which one was
better
it's a very difficult choice the pasta
we made at home was incredible it was so
cool that we could just make that like
just putting a little bit of flour a
little bit egg - it's delicious
boom you got pasta yes but the pasta at
that restaurant was just like all those
flavors just taking to the next level I
don't even like eggplant parmesan
and that was incredible there were so
many layers of flavor there it was very
very good I really wanted my own pasta
making skills to win no but my winner is
the night out now I have to work on my
own post hockey skills sweetie
my winner is the night in yeah I like
your father frost that what we made came
very very close it was fine and it was a
really fun that inspires me to make more
pasta at home I love that you win either
way
well thank you so much for watching
night-in night-out that is our last
episode in season 1 as always tell us
whether you like the night or the night
out we'll put our recipes down below
we'll see you and season two happy day
happy day tonight
levy the Ponte Ristorante Ponte means
point point hmm like Ponte Vecchio Ponte
Vecchio bridge bridge means bread okay
are you gonna say that I was gonna say
bridge that's pretty good
we input rides in here doing oh oh yes